[Musique]
Mark LKS, bonjour. Nous vous
interviewons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
YouTube qui s'appelle Sinkerview.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Euh oui. Est-ce que vous m'entendez bien
là ?
Oui. Oui. 5/ C.
Alors moi, j'ai eu trois vies.
Ma première vie,
j'ai étudié les études d'ingénieur
et puis philosophie et puis théologie.
Je suis devenu prêtre catholique
jusqu'au jour où j'ai décidé de me
marier. Et à ce moment-là, ben je me
suis retrouvé sur le trottoir
et donc j'ai dû réinventer un autre job.
J'ai eu un peu de chance. Après quelques
années, je me suis retrouvé au sommet de
la Commission européenne
au moment où Jacques de h était en train
de créer sa cellule de prospective.
Et moi, j'étais chargé des religions, de
l'éthique, de la sociologie, de
l'histoire, enfin toutes les soft
matters dont les autres ne voulaient pas
s'occuper.
Comment ça s'est passé votre conversion
de de prêtre à homme marié ? Vous avez
rencontré votre femme ? Vous étiez
encore au presbitère ou
non ? Je vivais en communauté.
Euh
c'était une sœur.
Non, mais je dirais ceci, c'est que euh
moi, j'ai joué le jeu de l'église, j'ai
même connu les soutanes, hein. Attends,
je je je viens 60, je suis entré au
séminaire, j'avais
on était en 63, c'était avant le
concile, donc soutane et tout le bazar.
Et petit à petit, je me suis dit
le célibat, ça c'est pas pour moi. Et
donc quand j'ai pris la décision de
de renoncer à vos vœux.
Oui, j'ai pas de vœux moi. Les prêtres
font pas de vœux. On signe un quart de
feuilles. Voilà, je m'engage au célibat,
c'est tout. Et puis on signe. Même pas
une feuille entière, une demi-feuille.
C'est tout. En fait, c'est très bizarre.
On n'est pas des moines du tout. Euh et
donc c'est tout à fait
Alors plus je faisais théologie, plus je
me suis rendu compte que ça ne tenait
pas debout.
De quoi ? La religion ou
le célibat d'abord hein ? On va
commencer par ça.
Et donc une fois que j'ai commencé à
comprendre que moi je n'allais pas
terminer ma vie en célibataire et bien
j'ai fini par rencontrer une très
gentille femme avec laquelle je me suis
marié. À ce moment-là, bon ben je me
suis retrouvé sur le trottoir au niveau
professionnel.
Voilà.
Vous avez annoncé ça comment votre
hiérarchie ?
Alors c'est belge. Je suis allé chez le
cardinal. Ah Marc, je suis content de te
voir. Je suis très content de ton
travail. Je lui dit "Écoutez, monsieur
le cardinal,
je vais me marier. Tu sais ce qu'il me
répond ? Tu sais ce qui me répond ? Au
fond, tu as pas tort ? Je l'ai dit ou
pas ? On doit changer ces ces bêtes
règles. Mais le pape n'est pas d'accord
donc j'ai rien faire pour toi. Bye bye.
Bonne chance et on reste copain.
Donc ensuite vous avez fait quand même
un pied en théologie.
Oui.
Euh donc j'ai fait un un doctorat à Rome
en italien. J'ai appris le grec et le
russe. Donc j'ai appris les trois à la
fois.
C'était passionnant. Et j'ai travaillé
sur un ami de Lénine qui a importé le
marxisme en Russie et puis s'est
converti à l'orthodoxie parce qu'il
s'est dit "Oui, mais attends, on peut
pas réduire tout
au aux rapports sociaux."
Et donc moi, j'ai je me suis tapé 2000
pages de russe philosophique.
Moi je ne comprenais rien du tout. Le
premier jour, j'ai lu deux lignes et
puis je me suis mis petit à petit.
Voilà. Est-ce que vous avez encore un
ami imaginaire à l'heure actuelle ? Vous
êtes encore croyant ?
Je suis de plus en plus spirituel et de
moins en moins religieux.
C'est-à-dire
alors
on va partir de Platon.
On est mal barré.
Platon raconte une histoire. Platon
raconte une histoire. Le sens de la vie
est ceci. La plupart des gens sont au
fond assis au fond d'une caverne.
Ils ont un collier de fer ici et un
collier de fer en bas qui les empêche de
se retourner vers la lumière.
Le sens de la vie est d'aller vers le
soleil,
vers le monde des idées, vers le bien,
le vrai et le beau.
Mais on est enchaîné au fond de la
caverne
et on regarde la télévision,
des jeux d'ombre.
Et donc c'est très difficile d'enlever
son collier et puis de se mettre à
ramper vers la lumière. Et plus on va
vers la lumière, plus on est ébloui.
Donc on a tendance à retourner dans le
fond de la caverne.
Et quand finalement on s'est habitué et
on a habitué son regard à la lumière du
soleil et qu'on rentre dans la caverne
et qu'on dit aux autres "Mais vous savez
la réalité,
l'être le sens de la vie, il est dehors,
il est pas dans la caverne. Ne
croyez-vous pas ?" demande Socrate que
ce ce messager va être tué.
Et ça s'arrête là.
On a on a un pote qui est le fondateur
du programme spatial français qui
s'appelle Jacques Blamont qui a écrit un
bouquin qui s'appelle le Introduction au
siècle des menaces et c'était par
rapport à
la consommation de viande, du moins dans
son bouquin, il parle de la consommation
de viande et il a été jusqu'à rencontrer
le cardinal noir à Rome pour dire voilà
vous êtes depuis 2000 ans les
responsables de la propagande, vous êtes
les meilleurs dans la propagande. Est-ce
que vous vous voulez pas demander à vos
administrés de moins manger de viande ou
d'arrêter de manger de la viande parce
que les fondamentaux de soutenabilité
sociétale ou sociétaux ne pourront pas
tenir la fonction exponentielle de
consommation de viande. Qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de cette démarche ?
Le fatigant ne fera rien mais je crois
qu'il y a bien pire qu'on fait. On est
en train de convaincre. Moi, j'ai une
amie chinoise qui est
qui a écrit le plan pour Science and
Technology for China 2000-20.
Bon, elle connaît un peu de sciences et
de technologie. Elle est aussi la
présidente de la l'Association chinoise
de médecine chinoise.
Et elle me dit "Mais
regarde tes cheveux, ils sont tout
blancs. Regarde mes cheveux, ils sont
tout noirs."
Nous, on mange pas de pain, pas de
beurre, pas de lait.
On mange sain, on mange très très peu de
viande, on le met éventuellement des
petits morceaux dans dans une grande
soupe.
Donc vous mangez mal, vous vivez mal et
vous êtes en plus en train de mettre
McDonald's à Pékin et de convaincre les
gens de manger de la viande. Donc c'est
juste la Banque mondiale. Tout ce que
vous faites, c'est faux.
Faux et bête.
Et donc déjà si on pouvait arrêter de
convaincre
x milliards de Chinois de commencer à
manger de la de la viande, ce serait
déjà fantastique.
Donc à ce niveau-là, on a tout faux.
On va passer à votre cursus européen.
Vous avez été conseiller Jack de l'or.
Euh vous avez participé à la création de
l'Europe, c'est ça ? Comment ça s'est
passé les départs ? C'est c'était
facile.
Jacques Deor avait un caractère de
cochon.
C'est quoi un caractère de cochon ?
Bah, il se mettait en route dès qu'on
dès qu'on le contredisait. Bon, mais
travailler pour lui était passionnant
parce que tu écris un discours pour lui,
tu vois qu'il a relu, qu'il a corrigé,
qu'il a mis des remarques en rouge dans
la marge.
Donc, tu sens qu'il travaille sur ce que
tu as donné
un minimum. Oui mais attendant moi j'ai
travaillé pour 100 il ne savait même pas
lire. Il pensait en allemand, il lisait
en français. Il comprenait rien de ce
qu'il lisait. Bon, il y a tout, hein.
Alors, la deuxième chose
euh et ça c'est quand même une
expérience très forte, il nous a dit
"Écrivez-moi un livre, un livre blanc
par moi
euh sur l'économie européenne dans 30
ans, 2040
ans.
Bon, on s'est mis à travailler et on a
expliqué quatre idées
200 pages mais je résume. On est en
train de passer de de l'époque
industrielle à l'époque immatérielle.
On va garder l'industrie mais les jobs
industriels
et les jobs immatériels, ils sont pas
encore créés. Et donc la jeunesse, elle
est le cul entre deux chaises. Bon, ça
c'est 1 2 il faut détaxer le travail, ce
qui est une vision industrielle et il
faut taxer sans pitié les pollueurs et
les spéculateurs qui n'apporte rien au
bien commun de l'humanité.
Des parasites,
voilà, ça on ne dit pas, on n pas dit,
on peut le penser,
on est sur internet,
voilà, mais nous ne l'avons pas écrit. 3
il faut changer toutes les structures
d'éducation.
à 180°, pas 10°gr comme on fait
maintenant, mais 180, c'est-à-dire
repenser l'éducation comme une formation
à la créativité. Enabling creativity,
c'est pas une formation, c'est
simplement laisser sortir l'âme des
enfants et la créativité.
C'est un autre paradigme d'éducation.
Vous avez dit l'âme, c'est quoi l'âme ?
C'est l'être.
Est-ce que vous pensez que
l'intelligence artificielle arrivera un
jour à toucher l'âme ?
Non, mais je pense
que nous allons droit
vers un débat sur l'éthique de
l'intelligence artificielle
parce que les GFA
et
les Californiens d'aujourd'hui sont
trois niveaux en dessous de mes amis qui
étaient les penseurs de la silicone
vallée il y a 30 ans. C'était qui ?
Willis Arman,
c'est l'edgar Morin américain. Génial !
Euh Harland Cleveland,
vice-se d'État de Kennedy,
bon pas un imbécile. Et le troisème,
Peter Drucker qui a écrit Postcapitalist
Society.
C'est le seul livre qu'on ne cite
jamais, mais c'est le grand penseur, le
plus grand penseur du management
mondial.
Ça c'est des gens qui vraiment
allez je vous cite une phrase de Willy
Arman,
on a tous son temps.
Willy Sarman dit ceci : "Nous sommes
dans une époque où l'humanité est en
train de modifier
The System of belief."
Donc système de croyance,
le système de croyance de la société
occidentale est en train de changer.
No économic, politique or military
force. Aucune force politique,
économique ou militaire ne peut arrêter
ce processus. Et il dit et en changeant
leur vision des valeurs de base de la
vie, les humains sont en train de
changer de civilisation.
Ça c'était des gens intelligents
ou utopistes.
Non, intelligents parce que ce qu'il
décrit, il faut lire son bouquin, c'est
exactement ce qui se passe.
Il a modélisé, il a anticipé
le fait que le système se rebife juste
avant de collapser.
J'étais
à Joui en Josas là avec mon ami Jean
Stone qu'il faut interviewer
de toute urgence. Il explique très bien
qu'en politique ça n'évolue pas de
manière linéaire,
ça fait des zigzags parce que vous vous
mettez à changer, les gens disent "Yes,
OK." Et puis tout d'un coup, on se dit
"Moi, maintenant on est en train de ser
la branche sur laquelle on est assis,
hop, on recule. Donc c'est la procession
de l'externact. On fait trois pas en
avant, deux pas en arrière. En
politique, c'est souvent comme ça. Et
donc la la mutation dans laquelle on
est, c'est une mutation qui va se faire
en zigzag. Ça c'est normal.
Si ça se fait pas en zigzag et s'il y a,
on va dire un séisme, une brisure et que
ça va pas dans votre chemin, est-ce que
vous êtes capable de faire l'avocat du
diable de votre propre prospective ?
Oui. Pourquoi ?
Je vous écoute.
Parce que personne ne sait.
personne ne sait.
La seule chose que j'ai compris, c'est
que personne ne connaît le futur. Plus
tu fais de la prospective, moins tu
connais le futur. Mais
mais ce qui est important théoriquement
la vraie politique la vraie politique
comme de l'UR l'a pensé c'est
imaginer des pistes du futur et
accompagner
l'opinion publique
dans son cheminement vers ce qu'elle
sent être le futur à créé. C'est pas un
peu paternaliste ?
Accompagner ? Ce n'est pas dirigé hein.
Cool.
Euh
soft paternaliste.
C'est-à-dire qu'en politique, tu te
rends compte
qu'il faut avaler beaucoup de couleuvre
euh que euh
tu es tu es confronté à ta propre
ambiguïté. Tu es une zone d'ombre. Mais
tu as des zones d'ombre dans la
politique, hein. Tu as des forces
d'ombre, tu as des forces Et donc il
faut
Quelles sont les forces de l'ombre ?
C'est d'abord notre peur collective du
changement.
C'est aussi les mafias,
les mafias politiques ou les mafias
mafia économique, mafique,
tu as toutes sortes de tu as des mafias
religieuses, l'oppos
et la mafia euh si tu veux, tu donnes ça
au début et puis tu es
Et donc c'est comme une intelligence
collective négative.
Attends, c'est fort, hein.
Bon et en politique, il faut tenir
compte de l'intelligence collective
positive mais aussi du négatif.
C'est ça qui n'est pas simple.
Alors, si on peut se tutoyer, tu es
belge.
Oui. Oui.
Le on on va envoyer un peu de steak.
C'est c'est ce soir, on est en direct,
il est 18h39.
ces forces de l'ombre si elles gagnent,
c'est-à-dire que si ta prospective un
peu utopiste de le changement de
civilisation, il va y avoir
l'empowerment de la population, la
population va s'emparer de ces nouvelles
valeurs, va y avoir un basculement des
consciences pour avancer ensemble. Euh
euh bon d'accord, si ça marche pas, si
les entre guillemets les forces de
l'ombre gagnent, c'est-à-dire que le
capitalisme prédateur a servi l'esprit
critique de la masse, que la masse est
mise en esclavage par de l'intelligence
artificielle ou on va dire remis au
rebut, qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
Alors,
il est clair
qu'il y a des gens qui désirent vraiment
faire ça et ils l'ont publié, ils l'ont
dit
qui
euh des gens comme ceux qui possèdent la
banque centrale américaine qui est une
banque privée.
Euh c'est toujours JP Morgan.
Euh tu retrouves toujours les mêmes
euh
il y a des gens le Builderberg, la
trilatérale.
On connaît la trilatérale. Qu'est-ce que
Qu'est-ce que tu leur proches ?
Mais ce sont des gens qui sont là pour
protéger
d'abord pour protéger leurs intérêts,
mais plus que ça, pour diriger le monde
vers une aliénation vraiment du grand
nombre.
Je crois
si si je te dis la démographie nuit à la
qualité des cerveaux, ça te fait penser
à quoi ?
Ben alors, on tue des gens hein, on est
on imagine des maladies, tout ça est
prévu et c'est possible. Tout ça sont
des scénarios tout à fait possibles.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Alors
moi ma conviction personnelle
mais
c'est un choix je sais
et je sens que ter de chardin le vieux
de jardin a raison et il a dit attention
les petits copains, au début du 21e
siècle vous allez voir l'humanité va
être confrontée à une série d'une
vingtaine de problèmes inextricables
insolubles et connectés les uns avec les
autres.
Makefa qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Et à ce
moment-là, dit-il,
comme dit Einstein, on ne résout pas les
problèmes au même niveau auquel on les a
posé. Donc il faut s'élever. Et il dit
voilà, c'est évident que nous allons
passer dans la nosphère.
Et moi je suis convaincu, je le sens que
nous y sommes déjà.
Il faut que tu explicites la NOSPhère.
Cette nosphère
pour
pour ta vient de nous et nous en grec
c'est l'esprit et l'âme.
Et donc la nosphère c'est en même temps
c'est-à-dire quelque chose qui nous
relie tous mais qui a une valeur
beaucoup plus subtile aussi.
Et donc je crois que nous sommes en
train de tous changer de niveau de
conscience. Sinkerview, c'est ça. Vous
êtes des porteurs de cette nouvelle de
ce nouveau niveau de conscience. Et plus
on est dans l'anosphère, mais plus on
est furieux.
On est furieux parce que parce qu'on
voit de plus en plus et de mieux en
mieux et de plus en plus clairement tout
ce qui est merdique
et ce qui est positif.
Et ce qui est positif.
Et les gens sont furieux. C'est ça qu'il
faut expliquer aux gens, c'est que leur
colère quelque part est liée au fait
que même change de niveau de conscience.
Me s'en rendre pas compte parce qu'il
regarde vers le bas, il regarde pas vers
le haut.
Enfin voilà, ça c'est ma vision à moi.
Est-ce que tu connais Krishna Murti ?
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Ce que j'ai lu quelque part, c'est que
il était appelé à quelque chose de
extraordinaire et qu'il a refusé. Donc
ça reste un très grand spirituel, mais
quelque part, il n'a pas réalisé ce
pourquoi il était euh
prédestiné.
Oui, mais génial, hein.
Et je crois d'ailleurs que Jésus ne
voulait pas du tout de fonder de
christianisme.
Jésus, tu parles de qui ? du leader de
la secte chrétienne il y a 2000 ans.
Je crois que Jésus était un grand initié
par qui
il a subi pas mal d'initiations.
Probablement qu'il est allé, il a fait
le tour de l'Inde et cetera. On ne sait
pas ce qu'il a fait entre 15 et 30 ans.
Il y a des livres qui disent ça. Je je
crois que c'est Et la seconde chose,
c'est que probablement son message
c'était la transfiguration.
Ça c'est le vrai message.
Et et le clerger euh euh
bah non, attends
a dévoyé le message, c'est ça.
Mais ils ont rien compris évidemment.
Et donc le niveau énergétique de
l'humanité il y a 2000 ans n'était pas
capable.
Ça veut dire quoi énergétique d' ans ?
Parce que là là c'est c'est
le niveau de conscience, je dirais la la
capacité de comprendre. Il avait choisi
des gens très humbles mais tellement
humbles qu'ils n'ont pas compris. Mais
d'ailleurs les intellectuels n'ont pas
compris. La seule qui avait compris
c'était la femme de Pilate qui lui a dit
"Attention chérie, ce type là, j'ai eu
un rêve." Bon, mais
ça a mal terminé, hein.
Ça a mal terminé. Et euh
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de Saül ?
Saül qui a fait tomber le temple là ?
Oui, je sais pas.
Mais euh la chose la plus intéressante
dans l'Évangile, c'est quand même la
transfiguration,
c'est-à-dire la transformation
des cellules du corps et de l'ADN des
cellules du corps. C'est ça que Jésus a
probablement fait.
C'est qu'il faisait déjà de
l'épigénétique avant tout le monde.
Oui, tout à fait. L'épigénétique est en
très bas niveau, une un début de
commencement d'explication de ce qui est
en train de se passer.
On on revient sur l'Europe.
Ouais,
parce que là, on dévie un peu.
Ça intéressant aussi hein.
On va y revenir, il y a pas de problème.
C'est l'avantage de notre format. Euh,
est-ce que l'Europe a été fondée sous
influence américaine pour faire un
déboucher pour le marché américain ?
Alors,
est-ce que l'Europe est gangrainée,
verolé, infiltré par des éléments
extérieurs américains pour influencer
les décisions de l'Europe ?
du temps de l'or non maintenant oui.
Mais il faut lire les mémoires de
monnaie.
Les mémoires de monnaie expliquent ceci.
En 49,
les Anglais sont allés au département
d'État et moi je le sais par Arland
Cleveland qui était en train de préparer
le plan Marchal. Il était responsable du
plan Marchal pour l'Europe. Enfin bon.
Et le type me dit Arland Cleveland, on a
reçu les les English d'abord qui nous
ont dit Commonweeth, Commonwalth,
Commonwealth marcher marcher, marcher.
Et puis la semaine suivante, on a reçu
Mony et Schuman
et on s'est dit "It's better,
it's better."
Et donc les anglais furieux mais furieux
sur les Américains de ne pas avoir été
accepté et de voir que c'est quand même
l'autre projet de Schuman
et Money qui est accepté. Bon,
alors il y a autre chose aussi.
Le 9 mai 50
Oui. 1950
M s'amène chez Adon
et Adon le laisse parler pendant 1 heure
et puis lui dit
"Monsieur Monnaie, je vous attendais
depuis plusieurs années.
Je suis intéressé par ce que vous dites,
mais je vais vérifier que votre
gouvernement
vous soutient.
Si c'est vrai, vous pouvez compter sur
moi jusqu'à la fin de ma vie.
Je vous trouverai des Allemands de très
haute qualité
pour travailler au niveau européen.
Et Monie qui est un AT
de bon
dit
cette journée fut magique, je dirais
presque spirituelle. Point.
Il a touché un chèque ?
Non
non, il vendait du cognac qui s'en
foutait.
L'Europe de maintenant, Mastrich,
qu'est-ce qu'on en pense ?
Alors,
ça a été un petit peu passé. L'Europe
qu'on avait pensé avec Jacques de était
de centre gauche. Elle est devenue ultra
ultra ultra libérale. C'est-à-dire
qu'elle ne elle ne satisfait plus que
quelques multinationales et encore
et donc c'est tout faux. Tout ce qu'ils
font pour le moment est faux. Pour sur
les semences, ils se sont trompés. Sur
Monsanto, ils se sont trompés.
Tout est faux.
Mais qui a écrit les traités ? C'est
quand même nous il y a 20 ans.
L'article 50, ça vous parle ?
Il y a bien pire. L'article 123,
ça dit
l'article 123 est le pire des articles
qu'on n'est jamais écrit.
Ça interdit aux banques centrales de
faire de l'argent
et ça oblige les banques centrales de
demander aux banque de faire de l'argent
pour eux et puis de le prêter à la
banque centrale avec un intérêt. Et donc
toute la crise de la dette est produite
sillamment par l'article 123.
C'est toi qui écrit ça ?
Et ça a été écrit ça s'appelle
C'est toi qui a écrit ça ?
Non c'est pas moi qui a écrit l'article.
Je suis rassuré.
Mais c'est probablement JP Morgan et
quelques-uns toujours les mêmes.
C'est c'est
à servir les peuples par la dette.
Oui.
Pourquoi personne le dit ?
Je sais pas
parce que quand tu le dis les gens ne
publient pas. Tu vois si je vais dans
journal Le Monde qui l'a dit c'est
Rocard avant de mourir et puis il est
mort.
son dernier vidéo, tu vas voir sur
YouTube le dernier vidéo de regard, il
explique ça.
C'est beau quand même.
Oui, c'est pas mal.
Pourquoi il faut attendre que les vieux
soient vieux pour que ils commencent à
l'ouvrir ?
Bon, nous l'avons dit dans le rapport du
club de Rome au Parlement européen,
c'est marqué
qui s'appelle en français Non à la
toute-puissance des banques. Un tout
petit sous-titre, rapport du Parlement
européen, du club de Rome au Parlement
européen sur la monnaie. C'était quelle
année ?
Euh 2013 2014.
Tu sais ce que ça veut dire ? Si on a
servi les peuples par la dette, c'est
qu'ils vont toujours courir pour pouvoir
rembourser. Et c'est
alors
c'est une concentration de pouvoir
extraordinaire.
Ce qu'on a fait avec la Grèce, tout
faux.
Parce que de l'or, tu tentes de l'or
quand les espagnols sont entrés, les
Portugais et les Grecs, on a dit "Ah,
ils ont des énorme." Très bien. Très
bien.
Et de leur a dit "We give, nous donnons
de l'argent, nous ne prêtons pas".
Pourquoi ?
Quand tu vois la gestion du franc
français à Ber chaque année on fait les
comptes. L'Ardèche est en dessous de
zéro. La drôme est en dessous de zéro.
Bon le Z le la
la Corse est en dessous
la Corse et et la Zambaise la Corèse.
Bon que fait Bercy ? Bah elle les met à
zéro.
Elle empreinte pour eux sur les marchés.
Oui tout à fait mais à 1 %.
05 maintenant ça doit
tandis que si tu dis à la coresse
d'emprunter sur le marché mais elle va
payer 15 %. Et donc de l'or a toujours
imposé au chefs d'état
que à l'intérieur de la zone euro, il
faut donner de l'argent à des
conditions. Si tu donnes 100 milliards à
la Grèce, ben ils vont accepter. Et par
exemple, tu mets comme condition, il
faut que l'église orthodoxe paye cet
axe.
Bon, il n'y a que de l'extérieur que tu
peux le faire parce que bouger l'église
orthodoxe en Grèce, attends, il faut le
faire. Bon,
c'est une mafia. Mais tu peux dire hein,
c'est une mafia l'église orthodoxe.
Mais c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont là depuis
ils ont été
la puissance qui a aidé les Grecs à
tenir le coup pendant 700 ans de
domination turque.
C'est un peu comme l'église catholique
en Pologne. Ils font partie de
l'identité nationale et donc c'est très
difficile de bouger à ça. Mais tu peux
le dire, écoutez, on vous donne 100
milliards, mais next year l'église doit
payer cet axe.
Et on fait venir l'église orthodoxe à
Bruxelles et on leur dit écoutez voilà
bon ça c'est le genre de chose qu'on
pourrait faire mais pour ça il faut
construire l'Europe politique et nous
imbécile on l'a pas fait donc de l'or
est parti en disant il faut construire
on a fait le l'euro mais il faut il faut
la la le guidon politique pour manager
cet eurou
bon maintenant on fait quoi parce que là
il y a
il faut construire l'Europe politique.
Ouais, mais d'accord, faut construire
l'Europe politique, mais c'est c'est un
peu trop tard quand même. Là là là, tout
le monde réclame des Kaisers, tout le
monde veut faire Brexit d'un côté. Il y
a plus de 50 % des Polonais qui se
disent "Bon, quand même hein, l'Europe,
il y en a un peu marre. Il y a une
augmentation, il y a une augmentation
des des nationalismes.
Tout à fait. Euh la Catalogne,
l'Italie du Nord, les flamands,
ça ça me dérange pas moi.
Ça c'est il faut pas tout mélanger.
Non, mélange pas.
Euh le la Catalogne n'est pas du tout un
mouvement
nationaliste,
c'est un mouvement,
c'est un mouvement séparatiste
d'autonomie.
Oui. Non, c'est un mouvement d'autonomie
pour le pognon.
Moi ça me dérange pas qu'on fasse une
Europe. Il suffit d'ajouter une petite
phrase dans le traité en disant le
traité est composé de 28 États membres
ou de 384 régions.
La fameuse Europe des régions.
Bah oui. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on a créé le
comité des régions avec Jacques de l'or
? Bah c'est parce qu'on s'est dit
attends on ne sait jamais.
Autant avoir une structure et les
imbéciles de Catalan ne sont même pas
allés au comité des régions qui leur
redonnent la salle de presse, tout ce
qu'ils voulaient. Ils n'ont même pas
pensé.
Bon,
donc c'est quoi l'Europe politique ?
C'est quoi créé l'Europe politique ?
C'est d'abord la gestion
de l'euro.
Il faut beaucoup de force politique pour
dire merde aux allemand.
Et ça tu il faut une structure politique
et pour dire attention
à la fin de l'année
nous ne prêtons pas d'argent aux gens
qui sont endettés mais nous leur donnons
avec des conditions. Si tu reçois 100
200 milliards d'euros, tu peux accepter
quelques conditions.
200 milliards, ça fait beaucoup quand
même. Non
mais oui mais attends le trou de la
Grèce c'est ça ?
Le trou de l'Europe, il est à combien ?
Je sais pas.
Mais euh attends, quand il s'agit de
rembourser les banques, ils ont trouvé
700 milliards en 2 jours. Ouais. Le
LTRO, le quantité leasing et je t'en
passé des meilleurs. C'est ça.
Et évidemment, c'est ce que les ce que
les Allemands ne veulent pas. Enfin, le
type dans son wheelchair là, ils veulent
absolument pas. C'est créer des bons
européens. On les on on fait des bons
européens et on on
on fait de la dette.
On on fait des bons du trésor comme font
les Américains. Ou les Américains ils
font de la dette. D'accord. Les Tibons
Américains,
dans 30 ans, il est possible
qu'on ait un système monétaire parce
qu'on va monter de niveau de conscience
qu'on ait un système monétaire où il y a
plus d'intérêt.
Voilà,
ça c'est possible. Alors, tu parles de
niveau de conscience, j'adore cette
phrase. Euh
est-ce que tu es au courant de la
consommation énergétique, du pic
énergétique, de l'épuisement des
ressources, des choses comme ça ?
Tout à fait.
Donc, tu es en train de me dire,
je m'excuse, je vais vous choquer.
Ouais. le club de Rome. Et donc
Tesla
ou Ouais. Oui, le Serbe
a inventé une voiture
qui a fait 600 km
avec un moteur quantique.
On a fait brûler son laboratoire deux
fois et on l'a fait exploser une fois
pour être sûr pour être sûr
que ce moteur quantique bon il y a des
ingénieurs qui ont fait tourner ce
moteur quantique. Ils sont tous morts
dans un accident d'avion, de voiture ou
bien une intoxication alimentaire.
Tu es complotiste. En plus,
il y a un gouvernement qui l'année
passée, le gouvernement indien a dit
"Moi, j'ai pas d' j'ai pas de charbon,
j'ai pas de pétrole.
Euh moi je je donc il a demandé à
monsieur Twari qui est une toute grande
famille d'ingénieurs de l'Inde
de développer le moteur quantique
l'ambassade d'Amérique et l'ambassade
des plusieurs ambassades occidentales et
d'Arbis Saudite lui on dit you should
not do
pour ta propre sécurité
et donc il a décidé de mettre l'armée
autour du laboratoire
et continue
encore en ce moment
oui
Il suffit d'aller voir, on voit la photo
du moteur quantique. Bon, nous sommes
dans une phase
expérimentale.
On est en train de rattraper ce que
Tesla a dit il y a 100 ans. Ça fait 100
ans.
Mais si ce moteur quantique donc ça
consomme 50 W et ça produit 10000 W
indéfiniment.
Donc tu crées une centrale au lieu de
nucléaire, une centrale quantique
qui le coût de l'énergie c'est zéro.
Bon, ça fonctionne avec le champ champ
de planque. Je ne vous passe les
détails. Mais
ce qui est en train de se passer, c'est
que ça fou en l'air le programme
politique des Russes, des Saoudiens, des
Américains, de tout le monde
parce que toutes les guerres sont autour
de tube tube de pétrole
pipe
pipes.
Tu supprimes tout ça et tu mets
l'énergie gratuite
et libre
dans une société immature de
transformants.
Tu t'es déjà amusé à balancer, on va
dire 15 kg de céréal à 150000
sauterelles.
Je sais. Alors, je dis ceci, c'est que
nous sommes devant une société, je dis
qu'il y a à peu près 15 chantiers de
cette Acabila qui vont mettre 30 ans à
évoluer.
tu ne vas arrêter le moteur quantique
parce que moi je sais que Tesla avait
parfaitement compris et donc on va le
retrouver, on va le faire fonctionner
malgré tout le monde et ça va faire
péter tous nos schémas géopolitiques
bête et méchants. La trilatérale,
tu comprends ? La plaque tectonique la
trilatérale contrôle très bien la
vieille plaque tectonique, la nouvelle.
Ils savent contrôler la chute des arbres
mais ils savent pas contrôler la pousse
des arbres. C'est ça.
Non, il ne voit pas la nouvelle plaque
tectonique. Tu vois la plaque tectonique
industrielle va entrer en dessous de
l'autre. Il la voit pas la nouvelle. Il
la voit pas. Ils savent pas la
contrôler. Il la voit pas.
Donc ils sont très forts dans le
contrôle du vieux
mais ils ne voient pas le nouveau.
Donc c'est juste le contraire de vous.
Vous vous voyez le nouveau
et vous sentez le contrôle des vieux.
Mais
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'ils ne
parviennent pas à contrôler le nouveau.
Ils savent pas. Tu sais pas contrôler un
réseau,
ça travaille un réseau.
Ils savent pas contrôler le réseau. Bon,
on pourra revenir sur cette notion là.
Je voudrais qu'on qu'on revienne sur
l'épuisement des ressources. On va on va
admettre que Tesla avait raison que
oui, c'est une hypothèse de travail
qu'il y a dans les coffres énormément de
solution.
sur Tesla qu'il faut lire absolument
qui est
c'est Théodorani. Alors Théodorani est
un génie qui est professeur à l'univers
du Bologna
mal vu parce que fou
un surdoué et donc son bouquin sur Tesla
et sur David Baum c'est génial
absolument génial il explique
tout ce que Tesla avait compris. Bon,
les félés les félés laissent laissent
passer la lumière, c'est ça ?
Non, il explique même que les génies
comme Einstein et Tesla étaient des gens
qui étaient connectés à la mémoire
akachique de l'humanité. Mais enfin bon,
ouais,
c'est un physicien quantique hein.
Ouais.
Et il l'explique à partir la physique
quantique. C'est ça qui est passionnant.
Bon là ça vient ça devient un peu
mystique. Bon revenons revenons sur la
la l'énergie libre dans une société
transformant
immature.
Si je donne l'électricité gratuite à
tout le monde, si je donne l'électricité
gratuite à toutes les les industries,
est-ce que elles vont grâce à ça épuiser
encore plus ? Qu'est-ce qu'elles vont
faire ? Est-ce qu'on a 30 ans pour
changer la mentalité alors que ça fait
plus de 50 ans qu'on apprend aux gens
depuis le berceau qu'il faut consommer,
consommer consommer sur une fonction
exponentielle ?
Un changement Thomas Kun explique ça
très bien, un changement de paradigme.
Il faut attendre que les vieux schnok
ou bien meurent ou bien prennent la
pension.
Il faut 30 ans minimum. H
donc moi je dis euh avec de l'or, on
avait dit attention, c'est il y a 25
ans, on est en train d'y arriver.
Euh
je te coupe, je te coupe parce que là je
suis obligé de te couper. Tu as pas
l'impression que les vieux Schn qui sont
en train de claquer ou du moins qui
attendent leur pension avec gourmandise,
ils ont mis derrière eux où ils ont
sélectionné des jeunes qui leur
ressemblaient, c'est-à-dire déjà vieux.
Oui oui
mais Thomas Kun explique très bien que
quand tu arrives avec un Einstein qui
arrive avec la relativité
restreinte d'abord et puis générale et
pour finir on a tellement pressé sur le
pauvre Einstein qu'il a désavoué sa
relativité générale mais il avait
raison. Bon euh Thomas Cun dit il y a
quatre stades. D'abord on t'ignore et
puis on te critique en disant que tu es
irrelevant. En plus parfois on te fait
des menaces de mort et le 4e stade on
dit mais we always said that.
Et donc ce type qui a écrit
c'est rien du tout. Bon euh
nous sommes au stade 2 31
euh mais
ce n'est pas un simple petit changement
de paradigme,
c'est beaucoup plus où les Sarman
expliquent qu'on change de métaphysique.
Alors maintenant vous tenez bien à votre
fauteuil.
Allez accrochez-vous les gars,
accrochez-vous. Il dit ceci.
À leur naissance, c'était un changement
de vision copernque. C'est pas la terre
qui est au centre, mais c'est le soleil.
C'est la terre qui tourne autour du
soleil. Attends,
c'était le contraire de tout ce que
disait l'église, les les astronomes,
enfin tout le monde. Bon, c'était un fou
ce copernic. La vision change et la
technologie change. Il y a Gutenberg qui
imprime la Bible. Ça change tout. Donc
c'était la vision et l'outil. Et
aujourd'hui, il dit il dit ceci. La
vision c'est
ce n'est pas la matière qui est
première, c'est la conscience
qui fait se cristalliser la matière.
Ça c'est ce que dit Willy Sarman. Et
l'outil c'est le web, le web open
source.
Et il dit ces deux choses-là vont
changer le 21e siècle. Nous sommes en
pleine renaissance mais le début de la
renaissance ça tape dur hein. Galilée
attend il a senti le vent du boulet et
maintenant on sent le bon le vent du
boulet mais Galilée l'a gagné
et donc c'est exactement nous sommes au
début d'une renaissance mais une
renaissance attends parce que dire que
la conscience est plus importante que la
matière il faut le faire hein. Tu dis ça
dans universités, on te on te donne zé
sur 20 parce qu'on ne peut pas te
brûler. Évidemment, aujourd'hui, on ne
brûle plus mais si on pouvait, on le
ferait.
Bon, parle-moi un peu de ton bouquin là
avec les crapaux.
Les crapaux,
ce sont les hackurs du futur.
C'est tout des jeunes.
Ah, ça c'est quelque chose d'amusant
aussi. Attends, je le retrouve.
Tu as pas mis de note.
Ah voilà,
il y a une courbe de gause. Les les
crapaux fous sont les gens qui sont tout
au début de de fous qui qui pensent tout
à fait autrement. Et puis petit à petit
la courbe monte et tout le monde
commence à dire mais oui mais oui mais
oui. Et puis il y a les early adopters
et puis les types qui tout à la
finissent par comprendre et ils disent
voilà
les crapaufaux ils sont là, ils
annoncent le début du changement on les
prend pour des fous mais c'est pas grave
et ils sont en train de montrer que on
peut
que la technologie actuelle
les algorithmes, tout algorithme est un
choix de valeur
évidemment
et Donc l'important c'est pas
l'algorithme, c'est le choix de valeur
qui a derrière.
Et c'est de ça qu'il faut s'occuper. Et
ça les types des gafas, ils ne
comprennent pas
ou ils comprennent trop bien.
Non, ils comprennent plus parce que le
niveau est descendu. Moi, j'ai vu ça en
Californie. Le niveau de réflexion de
mental level,
des types comme Willy Sarman, plus
personne ne les cite, plus personne ne
les lit.
le niveau a descendu et quelque part ils
font tellement de milliards
que
et alors c'est des cursoel
qui est très bas niveau, intelligent
génial mais de très bas niveau, qui
domine et qui a créé son Singularity
University
qui est génial mais stupide parce qu'ils
se trompent de paradigme. Ils sont
exactement retournés dans le paradigme
moderne scientifique.
Bon,
cool. S'il gagnent ces gens-là, du moins
s'ils arrivent à imposer suffisamment
longtemps leur paradigme ou du moins
leur vision de du basculement,
euh
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Tu sais ce qu'ils vont faire ?
Ils vont se faire pendre.
Non, ils vont ça va se passer. On va
injecter dans des volontaires
petite injection et là-dedans, il y a un
milliard de petit ordinateur biologique
de la taille d'une cellule qui
s'autorproduisent dans l'organisme.
D'après
we will enhance human potential.
Donc on va augmenter le potentiel
humain. Donc ton fils à l'école, on lui
dit "Écoutez, il faut un peu enhance
human potential et on lui fait une
petite injection. Si tu ne fais pas
l'injection, on le met dehors de
l'école. Nous sommes dans 30 ans.
Ils vont injecter une centaine, un
millier de gens et puis on va se rendre
compte tout d'un coup
que les recherches actuelles du cerveau
montrent que oui, le cerveau a une
fonction d'ordinateur
de dispatching de l'information. Ce
n'est qu'une des quatre fonctions du
cerveau parce qu'on on a découvert
maintenant Pibram et d'autres ont
découvert que le cerveau est aussi un
émetteur, un récepteur de lumière et qui
a communication entre le cerveau ici
mais aussi le cerveau du cœur et le
cerveau de l'intestin
des neurones dans l'intestin.
Oui. et qu' et qu'il communique. Comment
est-ce qu'une cellule tu te tu te coupes
ici ? Comment est-ce que le corps sait
qu'il doit reproduire des cellules de
main ? Mais attends, on sait pas.
Il y a une communication
de lumière
qui est et
il y a aussi une mémoire dans l'ADN.
Et donc les cellules parviennent à faire
la synthèse de tout ça. Donc là, on
revient à l'épigénétique. C'est ça.
L'épigénétique le début, l'embryon d'une
réflexion là-dessus.
Mais si tu
injectes tes ordinateurs pour enhance
human potential, tu ne fais que oui
augmenter peut-être peut-être une des
fonctions du cerveau mais tu tues les
autres. Et donc tu vas créer des
zombies, des Frankenstein.
Et quand ils en ont quand ils en auront
créé un millier, ils vont se rendre
compte. Et là Singularity University
disparaît du jour au lendemain et tous
les GAFA vont se réorienter vers un
débat éthique qui aura lieu où en
Europe.
Tu es optimiste ?
Non, il y a pas d'autres solution.
Et alors c'est
there is no alternative.
D'accord.
Mais c'est dans l'autre sens.
L'alternative,
c'est
les gens qui deviennent fous.
On va dire aux gens quand quand les gens
auront vu dans les journaux et sur
Facebook l'état des enfants auquels on a
injecté les fameuses
potions magiques. Attends euh
c'est la catastrophe, hein.
Et donc il y a pas d'alternative si tu
veux. Quelque part
est-ce que tu as déjà fumé du cannabis ?
Oui. Combien de fois ?
deux trois fois.
Tu étais prêtre ou tu étais pas prêtre ?
Non, c'était en Inde. Ça coûte beaucoup
moins cher.
En Belgique, c'est moins cher. Non,
en Belgique c'est moins cher aussi.
Bon, dis-moi si s'il y a pas de plan B,
s'il y a pas l'alternative, on va dire
on on s'approche d'un
l'alternative, c'est
la terre qui qui devient désert, hein,
et la vie qui disparaît.
Un effondrement de civilisation à grande
échelle.
Et je crois que ça va se passer en
partie.
Je crois que le système a besoin
d'une bonne purge. C'est ça
non ? En politique, les gens évoluent
avec un coup de pied au cul, quoi.
Malheureusement,
quand tu étais à l'Europe, est-ce que tu
trouvais les politiques un peu
rétrogrades, arriéré ? Oui. Est-ce que
j'ai surtout compris quand de l'or a
présenté son livre blanc au chefs
d'état, les chefs d'État ont dit
"Mrister Dolore, this is very
interesting. Let us go to the next
point," hein. Donccus.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il est très difficile,
extrêmement difficile en politique de
vendre le changement.
Alors, tu peux pas te faireilien.
Alors le premier politicien qui dit la
vérité, c'est quoi la vérité c'est que
il y a plus de job industriel, il y en
aura de moins en moins. On le dernier
rapport d'Obama qu'on a tenu secret
montre que dans les low wage job, 74 %
vont disparaître.
et dans les middle wage job, c'est 34 et
le highpid job, c'est 4 % qui va dispre.
Alors, attends attends attends le le IP
job, qu'est-ce que tu entends par iPad
job
? Au-dessus de 40 dollars l'heure. Donc
c'est IP job a-dessus de 40 dollars de
l'heure.
C'est ce que dit le rapport. Donc les
les 20 dollars l'heure, 30 dollars
l'heure, 40 dollars. Au-dessus de 40
dollars, no problem. Entre 20 et 30,
c'est 35 % de job qui s'en vont. Et dans
les low paid, en dessous de 20 dollars,
c'est 75 % qui s'en vont.
Ça fait beaucoup quand même.
Ça fait beaucoup. 75 c'est
ça. Il y a aucun politicien qui a les
couilles pour le dire parce que le
premier si tu dis la vérité mais tu vas
pas être élu, tu auras une statue sur la
place mais ta vie politique elle est
finie.
On fait quoi nous ? On fait on fait les
crapau fous.
On fait les crapau fous.
Allez continue.
Parle de ton livre.
Alors il montre
de ton livre
il montre qu'il y a trois
il y a trois dangers d'explosion mais je
sais plus lequel.
Je sais que un des trois c'est le big
data.
Oui.
Mais les autres je sais plus.
Tu t'en rappelles plus ?
Non.
C'est toi qui écrit le bouquin. Tu m'as
dit
non.
Moi, j'étais dans les crapaufous. On a
été invité dans une un endroit
merveilleux près de Marseille.
On a passé 3 qu jours à à discuter, à
échanger et cetera et puis tout le monde
a noté. Et alors, il y a
autour de Tem là, il y a une petite
équipe qui a écrit le bouquin.
Voilà, c'est absolument passionnant.
Ton deuxième bouquin que je vois par
terre, c'est quoi ?
Ça c'est mon bouquin.
Alors, ça s'appelle surgissement d'un
nouveau monde.
Vous pouvez aller sur mon site qui est
markleugs.
À gauche, c'est gratuit. Donc vous
l'avez mais pas avec le même titre pour
ne pas savoir d'ennui avec mon éditeur
parce que l'éditeur veut qu'on donne le
bouquin électronique à 16 €. Attend
donc moi je l'ai gratuit
mais si tu veux le papier alors là il
faut passer par l'éditeur et ça coûte 30
€. Mais à gauche tout est gratuit.
Voilà.
Et ce que je montre, c'est valeur,
vision, économie, politique, tout
change. Tout est en train de bouger.
Les religions, elles vont elles vont
quoi ? Elles vont accepter, elles vont
pas accepter ? Est-ce qu'elles sont
prêtes à sauter ?
Les religions, le danger,
c'est qu'elle devienne comme la
compagnie
des wagon lit russe
explique parce qu'ils vont pas
comprendre. Bon euh la compagnie après
la révolution russe, il y a plus de
wagon lit russes,
des wagons lit russes,
mais l'entreprise a continué à exister
avec des actions et cetera qui ne
valaient plus rien.
Et donc euh
il n'est pas certain, tu vois, Malro a
dit le 21e siècle sera spirituel. Il n'a
jamais dit religieux. Je crois que les
religions sont en train
l'énergie
dans la religion est en train de Mais
c'est vraiment comme ça hein.
Il y a pas de plus en plus de gens qui
se réfugient vers les les nouvelles
églises baptistes, les nouvelles sectes.
Ch clair, il y a des choses très
claires. L'évocation des jésuites sont
passés de 500 candidats à zéro ou 1.
Les prêtres catholique s'est passé de
600 de montants à de
l'éclaris c'est la enfin tout ce qui est
les vocation
c'est tombé à zéro mais zéro. Donc il y
a un mouvement très très fort qui se
passe. C'est la fin d'une époque.
C'est la fin d'une époque. Et je crois
que c'est la fin du de du religieux,
mais c'est le début du chemin vers
l'être.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses du terrorisme ?
C'est une secte comme il y a des sectes
fondamentalistes juives
chrétiennes.
Bah attends, les les types qui
colonialisent
les territoires palestiniens, c'est des
fondamentalistes juifs.
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses de ça ? Ben
c'est dégueulasse.
C'est dégueulasse. Et on montre très
bien, il y avait une très bonne émission
d'Arthé qui montre que ce
fondamentalisme juif
a pris un morceau du nationalisme
européen, une un morceau du
fondamentalisme juif. Euh, ils ont fait
une mayonnaise qui est extrêmement
solide,
mais euh ils n'ont pas d'avenir.
Ils n'ont pas d'avenir.
Il faut les aider.
Qui ? ceux qui n'ont pas d'avenir
euh Non, ils n'ont pas d'avenir. Ils
n'ont pas d'avenir parce qu'on va on va
quand même je crois même pas qu'on va
vers deux états.
Tout mur est toujours démoli.
Et donc le jour où on va démolir le mur,
ben on va arriver à à la conclusion
qu'Israël est un pays normal,
c'est-à-dire que one man vote et on va
voter et ça va devenir un pays
démocratique. Mais pas tout de suite.
C'est la seule solution. Ce sera pas
deux états, c'est inviable.
Je crois que c'est en c'est le jour où
le mur va péter.
On avait dit que le mur de Berlin était
là pour 100 ans. 2 mois après, il était
pété. On sait jamais. Le mur aux
États-Unis, tu en penses quoi ?
Ça n'ira, ça ne s' fera jamais.
Et le mur en Europe,
tu sais qu'il y a des projets de faire
des des murs en Europe ?
Mais
on sait pas si on va le faire en
Espagne, on sait pas si on va le faire
en Italie. Non non mais les hongrois
l'ont fait hein.
Non, ils ont pas fait un mur. Ils ont
fait des barbelés. Ça coûte moins cher.
Oui mais c'est
Ouais c'est c'est
c'est électrique hein. C'est étanche.
C'est étanche.
C'est la même chose hein.
Je les comprends. Je ne les approuve pas
parce que eux évidemment ils sont à la
frontière
ils sont sur une route migratoire.
Ben oui évidemment
ça déstabilise leur pays
parce que quand tu comp tu veux un peu
de jus de raisin ou c'est bon ? Je veux
bien un peu de jus de raisin si on a
quand tu compares la politique
allemande.
Oui. Oui. Alors, c'est du jus de raisin
agrémenté.
Hop là, je te mets jus. Donc je
t'écoute. On t'écoute.
La politique allemande quand même a
absorbé 1 million d'immigrés et les
Français n'ont pas été capables de et
les Belges d'enorb
plus. Ils ils ont absorbé 1 million
d'immigrés.
Pas encore. Là, ils ont en reçu un
million. Mais est-ce qu'ils sont est-ce
qu'ils se sont bien adaptés en en
Allemagne,
hein ? Oui, mais
Yve Montan, c'est un immigré.
Euh la plupart
Sarkozy, c'est un immigré
de noblesse hongroise.
Attends,
notre Europe vit aussi d'immigration.
Donc
est-ce que tu comprends les gens qui
s'arqueboutent face à ça ?
Mais oui, je comprends.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut leur dire ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
Mais par exemple à
à à l'air où il y a jamais eu autant de
murs dans le monde.
L'Allemagne de l'Est,
les Allemands de l'Est disent "Nous,
on croupit avec 600 € par mois et on
voit des immigrés qui arrivent et qui
ont 800 € par mois et nous on nous
laisse dans la merde. On crée pas de
job, il y a rien.
C'est vrai aussi donc c'est pas faux.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut qu'est-ce qu'on
peut attendre des politiques on va dire
dans cette are troublée à cette époque ?
Je vais donner une idée.
Notre politique vis-à-vis de la Turquie
nous coûte que 8 milliards ou ou même
plus.
Si tu prends ces 8 milliards et que tu
donnes 5 500 € à toutes les familles qui
qui intègrent un deux ou trois immigrés,
tu leur donnes 1000 €. Attends, tu es
une famille pas très riche, tu reçois
1000 € chaque mois pour accueillir
des immigrés. Il y a il y a 2 millions
de réfugiés en Turquie là qui sont on va
dire pas séquestrés par Addogan mais qui
sont retenus.
Il y en a 2 millions. Il 2 millions au
Liban. En Jordanie, il y en a il y en a
quand même un sacré paquet. Donc ça
c'est encore de la dette. On va leur
donner de de l'argent.
Oui,
mais l'argent c'est pas comme les petits
pains. Marque, ça se multiplie pas comme
ça.
L'argent est une convention.
Les Templiers en parler.
Le Bitcoin,
le Bitcoin, il y a des gens qui sont
tout à fait enthousiastes du Bitcoin.
Je dis que le Bitcoin est une création
électronique de monnaie mais sans aucune
garantie. C'est-à-dire que la monnaie
c'est une convention entre toi citoyen
et moi banque centrale qui dit je
certifie que cette monnaie est repayable
en or éventuellement. C'est fini ça.
Oui.
Oui. Mais enfin, je garantis moi banque
centrale que cette monnaie n'est pas
du vent.
Du vent même si là toutes les banques
centrales, elles font que du vent. Là,
les problèmes mandées,
il y a très peu de gens qui les
comprennent.
Ça tombe bien, tu es à la bonne place
pour aller comprendre là. Maintenant, je
vous donne juste une idée. Le plus grand
spécialiste sur la question monétaire,
c'est Bernard Liettard,
mon copain. Dans un livre de recherche
qu'il fait, il montre
que le problème sont les axiumes de base
de la monnaie. Nous avons créé une
monnaie rare.
Or, on peut très bien créer une monnaie
abondante.
C'est l'avantage des monnaes
alternatives, c'est qu'elles sont
abondantes, elles sont créées par les
citoyens.
Elles sont basées sur rien.
Euh oui, mais la monnaie de de
l'Amérique est basée sur rien aussi.
Exact.
C'est une convention symbolique la
monnaie. C'est depuis 72 où c'est plus
c'est plus basqué sur l'or, c'est ça ?
Depuis quand ?
72.
Alors, question d'internet. Il parle de
la fin des religions en se basant
uniquement sur la religion catholique.
Qu'en est-il de l'islam et du judaïsme ?
Qui parle de qui ? Quoi ?
Donc toi, Marc,
tu dis que la fin des religions en se
basant uniquement sur la religion
catholique, qu'en est-il de l'islam et
du judaïsme ? C'est question d'internet
formulé par qui
alors ?
On a fait un congrès à la Commission
européenne.
Tu es sûr que tu as le temps parce que
là il est déjà 19h24.
Moi j'ai le temps. Oui.
Sûr ?
Oui.
Bon
si je pars à 8h tranquille.
Tu es sûr de ton coup ?
Oui mais oui j'ai 8h25.
D'accord.
Allez 8h 10.
D'accord. Allez, continuer. Alors,
nous avons fait un colloque
sur
le changement de civilisation et la
religion governance and religion.
Nous avons invité le plus grand
spécialiste
de l'islam au monde qui est conseiller
de tous les grands gouvernements et il
habite Londres. Ramadan
un autre niveau.
Je sais plus son nom.
Et lui a dit "Ah, finalement des
occidentaux qui comprennent la
mutation."
Et bien dans l'islam, on est un
milliard, il y en a 2 300000 qui sont
dans cette mutation comme chez vous. À
peu près le même le même nombre. On a
quelques barbus emmerdants,
guerroyant et cetera, mais c'est pas la
grosse majorité.
Et donc euh je crois que le même
mouvement de recherche spirituelle,
on retrouve ça dans le soufi, le
souphisme européen, c'est une recherche
de plus en plus spirituelle, de plus en
plus de transformation personnelle
et qui est à mon avis moins religieuse.
Il me semble percevoir
que Mal avait raison. Donc le 21e siècle
sera spirituel ou ne sera pas. Mais
tu sais ce que ça veut dire ne sera pas
Oui.
Ça veut dire que ça va être une
boucherie. C'est ça. C'est une boucherie
sociale. Tout le monde sait chacun
chacun pour soi et Dieu pour tous.
Oui. Ou bien tu sais on peut avoir un
catélysme comme il y a eu pour la fin
des dinosaures et tr de l'humanité
disparaissent en une journée, hein.
C'est possible.
Bon,
tout ça est possible.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses du journalisme ?
Des journalismes ? Est-ce que les les
journalistes font correctement leur
travail ? pour informer la population de
toutes ces de tous ces enjeux.
Alors, si tu lis
une chose que j'aime bien, c'est GEAB.
Ah, le le le sing tank GAB de Franck
Bianquiri qui est décédé il y a bon, je
me rappelle plus
il a il y a 4 ans.
J'avais beaucoup discuté avec lui sur la
Syrie quand il était en train de se
battre.
continue.
Eux montrent, ils ont fait un schéma qui
montre que pratiquement toutes les
chaînes de télévision, les journaux,
tout ce qui est média et presse est
racheté par 4 5 6 personnes
et donc tout est jugulé. Là la
trilatérale marche à fond.
Ils ont jugulé complètement les médias.
Et donc par exemple, ils ont décidé
qu'on ne parlait pas des bricks. Brasil,
RA, India, China, South Africa, 4
milliards de gens qui ont décidé de
sortir de prêous,
ils ont fait
de créer une nouvelle banque mondiale,
de créer la route de la soie et cetera.
On a décidé qu'on en parlait pas.
Ben non, le mois passé. Her RTI parle de
ça. Ratoué, on parle ça
R.
Oui oui évidemment
Roché. Oui. China News. Oui.
Alors
le mois passé
la Chine décide dans un silence total.
Un petit article en 10e page dans dans
le monde la Chine décide d'acheter son
pétrole en yan convertible en or à Hong
Kong.
C'est beau.
C'est la fin du dollar. 1, c'est la fin
du pétrodollar. 2, c'est la fin de la
politique de Kissinger. 3 C'est la fin
de Breton Woods. Punto et Bastin.
Donc la fin
personne personne personne ne l'a dit.
On va pas parler de l'effondrement des
États-Unis comme ça, voyons Marc.
Non, on pourrait simplement constater
que c'est la fin de Breton Woods.
C'est aussi la fin des États-Unis. S'il
y a une dédolarisation du monde, si les
gens
c'est la fin. C'est la fin de l'énorme
avantage
monétaire qu'avaient les États-Unis,
c'est qu'il pouvait faire tourner la
planche à billet indéfiniment et tout le
monde accepte ces faux billets. Ce sont
des faux monayeilleurs
mais officiels.
OK. Mais c'est pas ça qui faisait le
plus peur, c'est que si les Américains
te sortaient de la zone dollar, tu te
retrouvais un peu en short en plein
hiver quand même. Non,
non, c'est pire que ça.
Le jour où la monnaie américaine
redevient une monnaie nationale, on va
dire
vous avez une dette
6000 milliards
qui non beaucoup plus que ça qui
correspond à une deux ou trois fois le
PIB mondial.
Exact. Exact.
Mais dans leur constitution, ils peuvent
la répudier. C'est marqué noir sur blanc
dans la constitution américaine qui
peuvent
le jour où il répudie leur dettes,
les bons du trésor
passent à zéro.
Et donc
le scénario du dollar qui tombe à rien
comme le Dutchmark a entre les deux
guerres
n'est pas du tout et ça veut dire que
l'armée américaine
rapatrie
ça veut dire que la police n'est plus
payée. Ça veut dire que il y a un danger
de guerre civile. Tout ça sont des
scénarios possibles.
Gab que le GEAB a théorisé il y a à peu
près 5 an
un petit peu mais depuis que Bierry est
mort c'est moins bien moins bien. Il y a
même un scénario
qui a été écrit il y a 5 J'ai reçu un
bouquin
écrit en allemand
qui s'appelle Palm Blat Manuscript écrit
en vieux tamoule par des richis des
sages Indiens au 16e siècle
et ils annoncent
d'abord que un des grands monuments
symboliques de la plus grande puissance
du monde vont être attaqués par des
objets volants.
Ouh là,
je t'avais dit par prendre du jus de
raisin quand même.
Et quelques années après, ils annoncent
mais je ne sais pas si c'est vrai, le
collapse de la monnaie de ce pays. Donc
c'est un scénario possible.
Et là l'euro ne va pas suivre. L'euro va
souffrir.
Tu es en train de me dire que on va se
faire attaquer par des petits hommes
verts qui v gagnent de l'espace là.
Non,
je crois qu'il y a il y a de la vie dans
l'espace mais je n'en sais pas plus.
Le Vatican, il a une cellule de
prospective sur ça ?
Non non,
l'Europe, ils en parlaient un peu de ton
époque
euh au Vatican ?
Non non. Est-ce que toi à l'Europe quand
tu bossais à l'Europe, est-ce qu'il y
avait dans la cellule de prospective
le des plans au cas où si on était
contacté ou visité ? un peu plus
officiellement.
Impossible. J'étais le plus ouvert mais
non ça ça n'est jamais passé la
tout ce qui est UFO et cetera sous coupe
volante. Non ça non ça n'a ça.
Bon ils sont ils sont très fermés
d'esprit quand même non ? Euh je moi je
crois évidemment qu'il y a de la vie
dans les autres planètes et que ces gens
vivent à des niveaux énergétiques
complètement différents. C'est c'est
pour ça que les sousvolantes
apparaissent et disparaissent parce que
ce sont des phénomènes énergétiques euh
que nous ne pouvons pas comprendre avec
notre physique nucléaire euh newtonienne
actuelle. Notre niveau de science est
beaucoup trop bas. Ils ont dû te prendre
pour un extraterrestre à l'Europe quand
tu leur racontais des trucs comme ça.
Non
mais
ils ont dû halluciner.
Je je cach faire halluciner pas mal là.
Je me cachais derrière Willis Arman et
derrière des Attends,
nous parlions tous d'une même voix hein.
Le secrétaire d'État
Arland Cleveland jusqu'à sa mort on
était grand copain. Lui était le
président de la World Academy of Art and
Science. Donc bah et donc on a fait
venir la World Academy of Art and
Science à la commission et cetera. Bon
donc ça avait l'air quand même assez
sérieux.
À la cellule de prospective, on faisait
attention à ce qu'on disait évidemment
mais ce qu'on a écrit il y a 20 ans
était quand même très audacieux.
Tu connais d'autres cellules de
prospective du moins de de centres
d'analyse de prospective stratégique
ailleurs ? Genre en Belgique, il y en a.
En France, tu les connais un peu ?
Alors, tout ce qui a existe, y compris à
la commission, ça s'appelle le GOPA,
Group of Policy Advisors. C'est nul.
Pourquoi c'est nul ? Parce que c'est des
planqués qui sont carriés.
C'est des planqués qui sont dans le
vieux système
et qui sont à la limite, ils sont
d'accord avec la trilatérale. Il a il y
a pas d'innovation.
Nous étions les seuls.
Par contre,
de mon temps, j'ai je me suis promené à
la Maison Blanche. J'ai été parlé au
groupe des policiers advisors et j'en ai
découvert deux sur les 12 ou les 15 qui
étaient ouverts, qui étaient mal vu par
les autres.
Ils sont encore vivants ? Oui, oui, mais
ils sont euh pensionnés, hein. Alors, je
suis allé en Chine
et j'ai découvert que euh
madame Jinjing qui a écrit le Science
and Policy euh for China
euh ce sont des gens qui changent
complètement de paradigme mais qui sont
minoritaires.
Non, il y a mes deux collègues qui font
les cons à côté.
Bon, passons euh
Non, mais si s'il vous avez des
questions, dites-le, hein.
Ah non, non, non, non.
Donc, allez, j'en ai une. Est-ce qu'il
connaît Nassim Haramine
et sa théorie du champ unifié ?
Oui, ce sont des génies ça. Il y a
Nassine Haramin
et il y a
Idriss Aberkan sur l'économie
immatérielle.
On va le recevoir Idris. Il faut que tu
répondes à notre mail.
continue.
C'est absolument génial hein. Ce sont
des des surdoués qui ont tout compris.
Ils ont compris quoi ?
Non seulement ils ont compris le
changement de paradigme,
les uns dans l'économie, les autres dans
beaucoup plus large physique quantique,
mais ils ont continué la recherche et
ils ont le génie de pouvoir bien
expliquer. Ce sont des expliqueurs
ou des beau-parleurs pour certains.
Oui.
Oui,
il y a toujours
Mais ça c'est le changement de
paradigme. Oui, c'est l'histoire des
Alors que je pense à la nouvelle
génération, c'était ça ta question.
Allez, raconte. Et puis j'aimerais qu'on
parle des enfants indigo après
la nouvelle génération. Mais évidemment,
vous avez raison
mais il faut pas trop le dire.
Mais évidemment, vous avez raison.
Évidemment.
Et
alors moi, je connais un type qui a
lancé une association pour aider les
enfants indigo dans toute la France.
Comment il s'appelle ?
Moi je ne sais plus.
Il est fort le jus de raisin.
Écoute,
j'ai son bouquin.
Bon, ça va te revenir, t'inquiète.
Attends, sur mon téléphone.
Non, non, non, le téléphone non, c'est
pas possible.
Mais
alors,
ça raconte quoi ? Il y a un bouquin, il
y a deux bouquins.
Il y a un bouquin français qui explique
que face aux enfants surdoués, il y a
deux stratégies.
Ou bien on dit ce sont des gens qui
dérangent l'école et l'université
et donc on va les droguer
des turlupins,
on va les
et on appelle ça hyperkinétique et donc
comme ils sont hyperkinétiques ils font
l'
hyperactif
hyperactif on va
ritaline c'est ça
la camisole chimique.
Camisole chimique.
et les autres qui disent "Oui, mais
attends,
leur disque dur annonce déjà la société
qui est en train d'apparaître."
Et donc ce sont des annonciateurs de la
nouvelle logique qui est en train et qui
est une logique beaucoup plus subtile,
plus fine,
qui est en train de
mettre du temps à se mettre en route.
Alors, il y a crayon. Crayon ça vous dit
quelque chose ?
Euh
c'est un américain qui canalise
bon et qui a écrit un bouquin qui a fait
100000 exemplaires, un succès fou qui
traduit en en 17 langues sur les enfants
indigo montrant aussi que dans
l'évolution
lui son point de vue alors c'est il part
des autres planètes. Tout le monde est
en train de regarder dans les autres
planètes ce qui se passe sur la terre
parce que l'évolution de la Terre
intéresse tout le monde. Parce que la
Terre,
tu connais le paradoxe de Fermi ? Non,
je vais continuer ce que j'allais dire.
Vas-y. Vas-y. Bien sûr.
La Terre est en même temps intéressante
parce que c'est très concret, mais c'est
des énergies très basses et d'autres
planètes se situent à des énergies
beaucoup plus hautes. Bon,
je parle en terme de fréquence.
Oui,
je sais pas, je sais pas, je sais pas
très bien.
Et euh la transformation qui est en
train de se passer
euh
est symbolique et importante
semble-t-il, pour l'ensemble de la
galaxie et même l'ensemble du cosmos. Et
donc les gens viennent voir
euh il y a beaucoup de soucoupes
volantes. Alors il y a
maintenant on se tient mais il y a
Kellart qui a écrit le dictionnaire de
l'impossible. Je sais pas si vous avez
déjà lu ça mais ça il faut lire. Alors
il explique ceci.
On a pris des photos
à Ternobyl et à Fukuala. Bon,
un jour avant l'explosion, il y a eu
trois soucoupes volantes qui sont venues
sur ces installations.
C'est quoi tes sources ?
Ben, justement celle dans dans
c'est quoi ces sources à lui ?
Il était là-bas sur place, c'est lui qui
a fait les photos.
Tu vas voir dans le bouquin. Je dis
simplement ce qui a été expliqué. Et
c'est un type assez crédible parce que
justement il fait des recoupements, il
dit voilà ce qu' dit dans le rapport de
la NASA. Bon, il semble que les
souscoupes volantes ont fait que
l'explosion Ternobyl soit 10 % de ce
qu'elle aurait pu être. Même chose pour
Fukishama euh Fu
Fukushima.
Fukushima
Les les extraterrestres dans ce dans ce
cas-ci auraient d'après Van Cowelart, il
faut aller voir dans son bouquin.
Euh,
il parle aussi de la transfiguration.
C'est amusant. Il y a il y a c'est il
dit voilà c'est impossible c'est
impossible qu'il y a des soucoupes
volantes qui est diminué euh qui est bon
voilà c'est impossible mais d'autre part
voici les témoignages de la presse de
ceci de ça.
C'estz intéressant il y a trois
bouquins. Il a écrit un premier
dictionnaire impossible un deuxième
dictionnaire impossible et le troisème
c'est au-delà de l'impossible.
Et ça c'est un channeling d'une dame
avec Einstein et Tesla. C'est
incroyable. Maintenant you likeot. Mais
l'avantage de Van Cowart, c'est que euh
il a une approche très cool
en présentant des faits.
Il nous reste 5 minutes.
Je vais venir à la Si, vas-y, pose ta
question. Là, il nous reste euh le Il
est à 42.
Et
laisse-nous un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Une bouteille à la mer qui sera
impérissable et immortel sur le net.
Alors
un ne vous laissez pas intimider par la
trilatérale
ou les autres
ou les autres. On n'est pas intimidé par
la trilatérale.
Oui, mais quand même ne vous laissez pas
intimider par tous ceux qui disent "Il y
a pas d'alternative", nous sommes
dedans, nous nageons dedans.
Il y a un bouquin qui s'appelle
l'intériorité citoyenne
écrit par Dansbourg, un belge qui dit
ceci
dans au 21e siècle, on va se rendre
compte dans les entreprises,
dans les groupes, même les groupes
alternatifs partout
que le gros problème des gens,
c'est leur ombre violente.
J'explique en deux mots. Dans mon
enfance, j'ai dû me protéger
de certaines souffrances et je me suis
fait des petites carap carapaces.
Mais après 40 ans, ces carapaces
m'emmerdent.
Mais je n'en suis pas conscient.
Et plus ces carapace me font mal, plus
je projette ma violence
sur les autres, que ce soit dans le
métro, dans la famille, dans la
profession. et cetera.
Et le chemin de l'être, un peu de
méditation et cetera, peut t'aider à
prendre conscience petit à petit
de cette violence que tu projettes sur
les autres.
Et donc
et tr
c'est pour ça qu'il parle de
l'intériorité citoyenne. Une certaine
intériorité, un certain chemin vers
l'être raté religieux on s'en fout est
aussi la manière d'être citoyen au 21e
siècle.
Bon Marc
le 3è point
il y avait un troisè
je ne sais plus.
Ah je c'est fort.
Bon c'est pas grave. Si tu veux tu
reviendras une prochaine fois pour nous
expliquer le troisème point.
Oui.
Bon merci d'être venu de Belgique et
puis ensuite de Jouill en Josas. Tu as
fait 2h de 3h de train aller, ensuite 2h
de métro et là tu vas te retaper une
heure de métro et ensuite 2h de train.
Euh merci de nous avoir parlé de ton
expérience à l'Europe avec Jacques de
l'or. Euh est-ce que tu serais intéressé
pour venir faire un panel avec d'autres
invités ?
Oui, il y a pas de problème.
Ouais, Marc, merci. À la prochaine.
Oui. Et alors, on peut aller sur mon
site,
c'est www.markleux.
Donc en un mot épelle épelle lex ça
c'est
l u y c k x
parfait marc merci
lux.be B
clap de fin clap de
[Musique]